[Music]
hey there friends Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love of
pois spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain um and we're back in
my living room with me giving you
another more informal kind of off the
top of my head lesson uh this time we
are going to be tackling up stalls cuz I
think that these are the Gateway way to
learning a lot of more advanced topics
when it comes both to stalls as well as
just some stuff in general about how po
moves and uh can also be helpful for
things like isolations too so uh before
we dive into that I do just want to give
a quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrot ter light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non- business
Friends of the channel Johnny Howard L
machinski and Becca beckan thank you all
so very much for your support for my
work and my mission brilliant so very
early on in my PO Journey um I
definitely was able to get down the
fundamentals of both down stalls as well
as bottom stalls both of these were
pretty pretty intuitive to me and better
than that they gave me a lot of
opportunities to be able to change the
direction of the poy however I wanted to
um I first realized that up stalls were
really a thing that I wanted when I saw
somebody do this going back and forth in
Split time opposites doing up stalls and
down stalls um that was really the
moment when it clicked for me of like oh
that's a thing that I really want to
learn how to do um so we were Off to the
Races and uh I discovered that those up
stalls required some knowledge that I
did not have yet um but I have it now
and I want to share it all with you um
so just in terms of stalls 101 I have a
way of visualizing stalls that I think
is somewhat unique which is that I think
of uh the PO as I'm spinning it as
basically going around a circle now that
Circle has a square around it
um now you'll notice as I'm drawing that
square um each side of the square is two
po lengths and there's a reason for that
because each side of that square
consists of two stalls uh let me break
down how this works here so let's say
that I'm going to do a down stall over
to my right hand side here what I'm
looking for is that moment when the PO
is passing by the point where that
Circle that it's spinning around uh
touches that side of the square and when
that happens my hand uh like the
straight line that I'm drawing with my
PO right now my hand goes along that
line and what'll happen with the PO head
is it'll drop straight down that side of
the square and here's where things get
interesting once the poy head drops
straight down one po length it's going
to run out of gas let me show you boom
like so if I bring it back the other way
I can do down stall to the other Corner
down to my right down to my left down to
my right down to my left really all I'm
doing here is I'm trying to create a
moment wherein um I can get the
relationship between my hand and po to
work in such a way that I am dropping
the PO head straight down for one po
length yeah like so
um you can just practice this by itself
if you want to just like hold the poy
head in front of you and see if you can
boom get your hand to come out to that
point and you'll know that you've nailed
it when the poy basically uh just stops
moving like if I don't get my hand all
the way out there the PO is going to
keep on swinging right if I overshoot it
again the PO keeps swinging whereas if I
get more or less right where the head
was it just comes to a dead stop you can
even have the hand go a little bit over
and down and it'll still work um but
basically you're just trying to get that
PO head to drop straight down for one
length of the PO right now this
knowledge is also helpful for tackling
uh the upall as well in fact it's
essential for tackling the upall um as I
was like working on trying to get down
up stalls for the longest time I
basically was like doing a pendulum
where it's kind of like flinging the PO
up a little bit to either side um wasn't
really what I what I was looking for and
there was a diagram that I ran across on
the home po forms at one point that
suddenly cleared things up for me which
was that um basically you want to
imagine that there's a direct
relationship between your hand and the
POI wherein um there basically it's the
inverse version of what happens with the
down stall where I'm trying to drop the
poy down instead as the poy head goes up
I'm trying to get my hand directly
beneath it and like the easiest and best
way to do this is just to have my hand
go straight out to where the PO head was
basically like if if if you think of uh
the PO tether as being like a line my
job is to take my hand along that line
to where the head just was like so yeah
it's almost like you're you're pulling a
lever right boom like so like so so as
you're swinging the POI around um
there's two tricks to this number one is
to recognize that your job is to get
your hand directly underneath the poy
head and the other is to recognize when
you start to do this because of course
if the poy head is already up you're not
going to turn it into a stall the trick
is to do it as the poy head is starting
to go up uh basically right as you're
starting to feel gravity uh leaving the
domain of the poy head you try and poke
your hand underneath it at first I kind
of overemphasized this where I was
almost like kind of tapping up with it
like so in order to make that stall
happen this is totally fine if that's
what you need to do in order to get that
feel of getting underneath the PO head
and making this happen that's totally
cool but the thing you're trying to nail
here is really getting your hand to
slide underneath that poy head right
there that's that's the money shot
that's what really makes all of this
work
and of course once you get that down you
can start playing around with doing that
same set of stalls in Split time
opposites that first inspired me to
learn to do those up and down
stalls as well as cool things like you
know stalling up stalling up stalling up
in opposites which you know is great
both for just kind of fun Dancy stuff um
you know and of course uh it opens you
up to being able to do some cool plane
changes and things like that too so
there there's no shortage of cool stuff
that uh this opens up for you but yeah
um it was definitely an aha moment for
me back in the day of seeing that
diagram of just like sliding the hand
underneath the PO head and realizing
that that was the key to the entire
thing like getting this linear
relationship to happen because just like
doing the down stall means that you have
to get the poy head to drop for one po
length in order to get the upall you
need the PO head to go straight up in a
straight line for one po length so get
that hand underneath it and make sure
that you're getting a full Poise length
worth the vertical out of it and uh that
will get you there of course coming back
out of it is going to involve pulling
your hand back and sometimes pulling
your hand down to really switch the
direction of the poy yeah awesome um so
yeah if uh you're enjoying this series
and you want to see more of them please
leave me a request for something you'd
like to see covered down in the comments
um if you like these kind of offthe cuff
lessons I do do live stream classes now
um you can learn more about them and
sign up over at crowdcast doio
drexfactor poy um yeah please make sure
to uh like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find these videos
and uh hopefully to help my channel grow
too right
[Music]
and before I set you all off uh this
video would not be possible if it were
not for the kind support of all of these
nice people right here uh these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description help to make this and all
the videos on this channel possible
thank you so much for your wonderful
support friends uh if you out there
watching are not currently supporter and
You' like to become one you can do that
by heading on over to
patreon.com factor Po and signing up you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards including a weekly
lesson that is exclusive to my patreon
supporters that is kind of off the cuff
like this that gets delivered to your
inbox every week um as well as early
access to my content um go check that
out please and thank you um and if you'd
like to see more tutorials that I've
produced over the years I will go ahead
and leave a link to playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you're watching this
video on YouTube um also YouTube thinks
that you like this top video based upon
your past viewing habits so maybe give
that a look as well thanks so much for
tuning in and I will see you with a new
video very very soon make sure to get
out and flow today and I'll see you soon
peace